hey kids feeling awkward because you're
a teenager and you haven't had sex yet
well according to Disney you should at
least that's the lesson of hocus-pocus a
movie starring Bette Midler as a leader
of witches who were axed off years ago
but a boy and his sister bring them back
to life by accidentally saying a spell
and now they're looking to take over the
town and of course run amok with the
help of a would-be girlfriend a boy who
was cursed to the body of a cat and even
a walking zombie our heroes have to see
if they can stop the witches in time
okay so I'm just gonna get to what I
really fucking hate about this movie the
most it's strange obsession that if
you're a teenager and you're a virgin
there's something wrong with you yeah
this is Disney I mean yeah I know your
whole sex is bad but we're actually
using sex to sell stuff is always kind
of there but oh my god you're not
supposed to be this insulting with it or
this direct the main character in this
movie admits that he hasn't had sex and
everybody
I mean freaking everybody has a heart
attack about it it's practically the
focus of the movie hell even the
finishing line centers around it and
don't get me wrong I'm not one of those
prudes that things like teenagers should
never talk about sex and they should all
live in happy places where sex doesn't
exist a weird shit like that but this
movie puts a lot of emphasis on if you
haven't had sex yet you're a loser and
you should be made fun of and this is
the way the world works yeah Disney has
kind of turned into that big obnoxious
bully at school and it's such a weird
thing for something like Disney to focus
on every time it's brought up I just
feel kind of dirty but taking that
incredibly distracting element out of it
now is the rest of the movie I don't
know it didn't do that much for me
either I mean there are some creative
elements like the look of it is kind
indeed and there's some fun goofy
Halloween stuff going on that's just
kind of a bland story that works into
the typical fish-out-of-water jokes the
main characters are bland the side
characters look neat but don't really
have that much of a personality
the only thing that does stand out is
the performances of the witches
themselves they don't have much to work
with but by god they still work with it
these are three very funny ladies trying
to make material that's not very funny
into something that's funny just look at
how quick they are look at their facial
expressions look how big they get their
eyes and mouths and yeah they're really
having fun here I guess on that level
the film is kind of enjoyable but again
I said they're not really given much to
work with and that still stands as
energetic and silly as they can make
their performances it still doesn't save
a bad script I don't care if you give
them song sequences I don't care if he
having ride vacuums you're still not
technically saying anything that's very
funny which is a shame I think this idea
could have worked I mean these are three
very funny actresses and the idea of
three witches now being resurrected in
current time that could be kind of fun
but a bland script makes it predictable
not very interesting and all that virgin
talk escalates into a series of
uncomfortable awkward moments I just
never quite got or understood it it's
one of the most bizarre focuses a movie
has ever had in terms of Disney so yeah
as you can tell not a big fan even
though I know these actresses are doing
their best it's still boring it's still
predictable and it's still uneasy I
don't know if you want the whole teen
sex thing done in a much funnier better
way I say either go watch a John Hughes
film or malcolm in the middle' but
personally I will keep kids away from
this like the plague seriously what is
your deal
you